[Music]
recaptcha has over a decade of
experience defending the internet
and recaptcha enterprise builds on that
experience to provide frictionless
security for your business
recaptcha enterprise is built on the
existing recaptcha api
and offers granular insight and
detection allowing you to understand and
tune the protection you need
for your website let's take a look at
what makes recaptcha enterprise
different there are three primary
advantages to note here
first recaptcha enterprise provides a
frictionless user experience
leveraging advanced risk analysis
techniques that distinguish between
humans and bots
without requiring customers to complete
a challenge
second recaptcha enterprise offers
enhanced detection
with granular scores reason codes for
risky events
mobile app sdks password breach and leak
detection
multi-factor authentication and the
ability to tune your own
site-specific model and finally
recapture enterprise provides the
support
like the slas and slos that you expect
from a google cloud product
so if you expect a lot from your
recaptcha integration in usage or in
support
or if you want to detect automated
attacks or threats against your website
that may originate from
human actors mobile emulators or bot
software
then recaptcha enterprise is right for
you for existing recaptcha v2 and v3
users
we've made it a priority to make
migration simple
so simple in fact that it should only
take two minutes
first navigate to your project in the
google cloud console
you'll need to enable the recaptcha
enterprise api
while you're here be sure to note your
project id
second navigate to google.com recaptcha
admin to find your existing recaptcha
site key
you can find your existing v2 and v3
site keys
under settings click the cog icon to
open the settings view
and then expand the section labeled
recaptcha keys
copy the site key
to perform the migration you can use
cloud shell
note that your account will need to be
either a project owner
or have the recaptcha enterprise admin i
am role
a major benefit of using cloud shell is
that all authentication is handled
automatically
as the cloud shell instance is already
tied to your user account
and its existing credentials however if
this is the first time you run a command
that requires credentials
you will need to authorize cloud shell
first
to perform the key migration you only
need a single command
run gcloud alpha recaptcha keys
migrate and specify the v2 or v3
recaptcha site key you wish to migrate
and the project id of the cloud project
where you enabled the recaptcha
enterprise api
earlier you should see a confirmation
that your key has been successfully
migrated
back in the cloud console we can see our
migrated key under security
recaptcha enterprise here we can see
analytics and manage the key moving
forward
and that is how you can easily migrate
your existing recaptcha v2 and v3 site
keys
to recaptcha enterprise for truly
frictionless security
to learn more about recaptcha enterprise
go to cloud.google.com
recaptcha dash enterprise
you